TONIGHT WAS VERY INTERESTING.
THANKS SO MUCH, GREAT SHOW
TONIGHT.
I’M LAURA INGRAHAM, THIS IS A
SPECIAL MIDNIGHT ADDITION OF THE
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" FROM
WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
AFTER WATCHING KAMALA HARRIS I
THOUGHT TO MYSELF "NO WONDER
JOE BIDEN HEADED TO GETTYSBURG
ON MONDAY" GREAT HE WAS BABBLING
ON THEIR ABOUT THE NEED FOR
NATIONAL UNITY.
HE HAD THE NICE GUY APPROACH.
THAT WAS ALL AN EFFORT TO
CONVINCE YOU THAT DEMOCRATS
STILL BELIEVE IN AMERICA’S
HISTORY AND OUR TRADITION.
BUT WHAT YOU SAW TONIGHT FROM A
HOTTIE, INDIGNANT KAMALA HARRIS
WAS WHAT THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN HAS
BEEN TO WRITING DON’T LIKE
TRYING TO HIDE.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS ARE NOW THE
PARTY OF RADICALS, BY RADICALS,
AND FOR RADICALS.
KAMALA HARRIS STRUGGLED TO LIE
AWAY BIDEN’S REAL AGENDA ON
LOCKDOWNS AND ITS TRUE PLAN TO,
FOR INSTANCE, ABOLISHED THE
FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY.
YOU KNOW, THERE’S A VERY GOOD
CHANCE THAT IF BIDEN WINS, THE
WOMAN YOU SAW TONIGHT WILL
BECOME PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
YET SHE REFUSES TO ANSWER
MULTIPLE, EASY, BASIC QUESTIONS.
>> HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE OUR
FUNDAMENTAL RELATIONSHIP WITH
CHINA?
ARE WE COMPETITORS, ADVERSARIES,
ENEMIES RUSSIAN MARK >> SUSAN,
THE JUMP ADMINISTRATION
PERSPECTIVE AND APPROACH TO
CHINA HAS RESULTED IN THE LOSS
OF AMERICAN LIVES, AMERICAN
JOBS, AND AMERICAN STANDING.
>> IF ROE V. WADE IS OVERTURNED,
WHAT WOULD YOU WANT A CALIFORNIA
TO DO?
>> FIRST OF ALL, IT’S INSULTING
TO SUGGEST WE WOULD KNOCK ANYONE
FOR OUR FAITH.
>> THEY’D LIKE TO KNOW IF YOU
AND JOE BIDEN WOULD PACK THE
SUPREME COURT IF YOU DON’T GET
YOUR WAY IN THIS NOMINATION?
>> THE 50 PEOPLE WHO
PRESIDENT TRUMP APPOINTED TO THE
COURT OF APPEALS FOR A LIFETIME
OF APPOINTMENTS, NOT ONE IS
BLACK.
THIS IS WHAT THEY’VE BEEN DOING.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT PACKING A
COURT?
>> Laura: IT KNOW, THE
QUESTION WAS ABOUT PACKING THE
COURT.
MAYBE SHE SHOULD’VE ASKED IF SHE
COULD’VE BOUGHT A BOUGHT A VOWEL
OR SOMETHING.
HONEST, PENCE WANTED ON SOME
QUESTIONS TOO.
BUT AT LEAST THE TRUMP RECORD IS
THERE FOR EVERYONE TO SEE.
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY, PEACE IN
THE MIDDLE EAST, HOLDING A CHINA
DOLL KNOCKED ON MY CHINA
ACCOUNTABLE.
BUT THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN KNOWS
MUCH OF WHAT IT HAS PLANNED
ISN’T POPULAR.
AND THEY KNOW THEY CAN’T DELIVER
HIGHER WAGES FOR MOST AMERICANS.
SO WHAT THEY DO -- AND YOU SAW
HER DO THIS TONIGHT.
WHEN SOMEONE IS AS LEFT WING AS
HARRIS IS, YOU HAVE TO ASK IF
SHE’S EVER GOING TO USE HER
POWER FOR THE GOOD OF THE MIDDLE
CLASS?
HOW ABOUT THE WORKING CLASS
CUSHION MARKED SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS, AMERICANS OF FAITH?
THE ANSWER, NEVER.
BIDEN WILL NOT ONLY MAKE YOUR
LIFE MISERABLE WITH LOCKDOWNS
NEXT YEAR, APPOINTED
UNFORTUNATELY MIKE PENCE DID NOT
MAKE TONIGHT.
BUT THEY WILL ALSO MAKE YOU
MISERABLE BY LEAVING YOU POORER,
LESS FREE, AND LESS SAFE.
KAMALA HARRIS, TRUE TO HER
LIBERAL SAN FRANCISCO POLITICAL
ROOTS, HATES MUCH ABOUT THIS
COUNTRY.
AFTER ALL, SHE BELIEVES LIKE
BIDEN THAT WE ARE SYSTEMICALLY
RACIST NATION.
THAT IS A POISONOUS, AWFUL,
TERRIBLE LIE.
THAT’S MIKE PENCE CALLED OUT.
>> THIS PRESUMPTION THAT YOU
HEAR CONSISTENTLY FROM JOE BIDEN
AND KAMALA HARRIS THAT AMERICA
IS SYSTEMICALLY RACIST.
AS JOE BIDEN SAID, HE BELIEVES
THAT THE LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS AN
IMPLICIT BIAS AGAINST MINORITIES
MINORITIES.
IT’S A GREAT INSULT TO THE MEN
AND WOMEN THAT SERVE AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IT IS REMARKABLE THAT WHEN
SENATOR TIM AND SCOTT TRIED TO
PASS POLICE REFORM BROUGHT
TOGETHER A GROUP OF REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS, SENATOR HARRIS
GOT UP AND WALKED OUT OF THE
ROOM.
WE DON’T HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
SUPPORTING LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
SUPPORTING OUR AFRICAN-AMERICAN
MINORITIES.
>> Laura: BY THE WAY, SHE WAS
SMIRKING THROUGH MOST OF THAT
ANSWER.
KAMALA HARRIS THREW DOWN THE
RACE CARD TONIGHT.
AND SHE LIED ABOUT WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID ABOUT
CHARLOTTESVILLE.
OF COURSE, SUSAN PAGE DIDN’T
CORRECT.
SHE DID THIS ALL BECAUSE SHE AND
JOE BIDEN CAN’T REFUTE,
CERTAINLY CAN’T BEAT THE TRUMP
PENCE RECORD.
TO A LOT OF FOLKS, A LOT OF YOU
WATCHING IN THE MIDWEST AND EAT
EAST COAST, HE REPRESENTS THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY OF THE PAST, SEE
FOR A PARTY OF 30 YEARS AGO.
MAYBE A LITTLE BIT MORE
MODERATE.
MAYBE FOR A LOT OF YOU YOU THINK
ABOUT BIDEN AND YOU HAVE A
NOSTALGIC YOU POINT.
BUT HIS TALK OF SCRANTON AND HAS
BLUE-COLLAR APPEAL -- IT’S ALL A
BUNK.
MOST OF THOSE FOLKS, THOSE
BLUE-COLLAR FOLKS, THEY ARE NOW
FOR TRUMP AND FOR GOOD REASON.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE A PARTY OF
WEALTHY DONORS AND RADICAL IVORY
TOWER TYPES WHO WANT TO IMPOSE
THEIR EXTREME ANTI-AMERICAN
AGENDA ON THE REST OF US.
THAT IS WHO THEY ARE TODAY.
SO ALL OF THE PAIN AND SUFFERING
THAT THE LIBERAL GOVERNORS AND
MAYORS HAVE CAUSED YOU, THAT’S
NOT GOING TO BOTHER DEMOCRATS OF
TODAY.
WHETHER ON MASKS, TRAVEL LIMITS,
THE RULES NEVER APPLY TO THEM OR
THEIR WELL-CONNECTED FRIENDS.
THEY SEE COVID AS A POLITICAL
GIFT.
WHICH JAMES FONDA ADMITTED
TODAY.
>> I JUST THINK COVID IS GOD’S
GIFT TO THE LEFT.
>> Laura: THAT’S REALLY FUNNY.
SHE DID SPEAK THE TRUTH.
WHEN THE OTHER CABLE NETWORKS
PUT THE CHART UP ON THE SCREEN
RIGHT IN AND DAY OUT OF COVID
DEATHS AND INFECTIONS, THEY ARE
NOT DOING IT TO EMPATHIZE AND
INFORM YOU.
THEY ARE DOING IT FOR ONE REASON
AND ONE REASON ONLY.
AS A POLITICAL WEAPON AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
KAMALA AND PRETTY MUCH EVERYONE
WHO COULD END UP IN BIDEN’S
CABINET WILL BE CLOSER
IDEOLOGICALLY TO AOC DONE
CLINTON.
IT’S A DIFFERENT PARTY.
NOW LISTEN TO HOW SHE SPOKE TO
THE PARENTS OF AN AMERICAN
HOSTAGE WHO WAS BRUTALLY
MURDERED BY ISIS.
THE INAUTHENTICITY WAS PALPABLE.
>> TO THE MUELLER FAMILY, I KNOW
ABOUT YOUR DAUGHTER’S CASE AND I
AM SO SORRY.
I AM SO SORRY.
WHAT HAPPENED TO HER IS AWFUL.
AND IT SHOULD HAVE NEVER
HAPPENED.
>> Laura: GETS READY TO HEAR
THAT A LOT IF BIDEN WINS.
OH, IT’S AWFUL, I’M SO SORRY
THAT YOUR JOB WAS SHIPPED TO
CHINA.
OH, IT’S AWFUL, I’M SO SORRY
THAT YOUR KIDS CAN’T GO TO IN
PERSON CLASSES BECAUSE WE ARE
LOCKED DOWN.
OR I’M SORRY IT’S SO AWFUL THAT
YOUR NEIGHBORHOODS AREN’T SAFE,
BUT WE WON’T OFFEND ANYONE BY
ENFORCING THE LAW.
I’M SORRY YOU FEEL BAD THAT
MOUNT RUSHMORE HAS BEEN
DEMOLISHED.
YOU ARE GOING TO HEAR THAT A LOT
LOT.
IF BIDEN HARRIS WINS, THE
POLICIES THEY WILL ENACT WILL BE
FAVORABLE TO PRO-CHINA, THE
PRO-CHINA CAUCUS ON WALL STREET,
AND IN BIG BUSINESS.
THEIR POLICIES WILL BE FAVORABLE
TO THE GLOBAL SCIENTIFIC
ESTABLISHMENT PUSHING LOCKDOWNS
AND CLIMATE CHANGE RULES.
THEY WILL BE SUPPORTIVE OF
LEFTIST IDEAS THAT COME OUT OF
ACADEMIA AND THEY WILL BE
HOSTILE TO THE MIDDLE CLASS AND
TRADITIONS.
THEY WILL BE HOSTILE TO THE OIL
AND GAS INJURY NOMADIC INDUSTRY,
TOTRADITIONAL CHRISTIANS AND
ORTHODOX JEWS.
MOST QUESTIONS WERE WORDED
AGAINST TRUMP.
SUSAN PAGE INTERRUPTED PENCE FOR
TIME FREQUENTLY AND LET HARRIS
DRONING ON AND ON AND SHE GOT
INDIGNANT.
PENCE DID FIND TONIGHT, HE
OBVIOUSLY WON.
AND HARRIS DID NOTHING TO
CONTRADICT WHAT WE ARTY KNOW
ABOUT HER.
NONE OF HER EYE ROLLING OR
GRIMACING OR THE INSECT MOVING
ONTO PENTZ’S HEAD IS GOING TO
CHANGE THIS SIMPLE FACT.
THE MARKETS WERE UP 500 POINTS
TODAY BECAUSE IT TRUMPS
RECOVERING AND GETTING STRONGER.
HE’S WILLING TO DO A TARGETED
STIMULUS.
I DO WISH THAT PENCE BROUGHT UP
THE ECONOMY THAT WAS SO GREAT
FOR THE WORKING CLASS THAT
AMERICANS DECIDED TO TURN OVER